ever since we discovered the horrors of
the Sun complacent get out we've been
wondering whether it would link to
Jordan peels follow-up movie us about a
family confronted by their doppelgangers
yippie Chi movie lovers I'm Jon and in
this video I'm revealing the hidden
connections between us and get outs and
explaining why the two movies likely
exist in the same universe spoilers
ahead for both movies so take care if
you haven't seen them yet the conspiracy
that Kris uncovers in get out is that
his girlfriend Rose and her family a
part of a secret society that's been
transplanting rich white people's brains
and consciousness into the bodies of
younger black men and women who've been
abducted the experiments in Earth's have
been carried out on larger numbers of
people but there are some major
similarities and connections between the
two conspiracies in peels new movie we
discovered that the tethered of the
product of an experiment carried out
underground the conspirators who set
this up plan to use the doppelgangers as
a way to control their look-alikes
above-ground a delayed counterpart red
explains that although the process
created a copy of a person's body it
failed to create a separate soul this
meant that the doubles below the surface
became tethered to the bodies above and
ended up with little control over their
lives because of the schemes apparent
failure to create an independent
consciousness in their subjects the
people in charge decided to abandon the
experiment and they left the tethered
alone in the tunnels to fend for
themselves
fast-forward to 2017 and get out where
Rose's family have almost but not quite
perfected a medical procedure where they
can transplant a person's mind into the
body of another human being
to see why the mad scientist's
responsible for the tethered in earth
could be the same ones who developed the
brain surgery that we see Dean
performing and get out we need to
examine a little-known secret about
guess out that Jordan peel is so far
only talked about in the special
features for the blu-ray on the movies
commentary track peel revealed that the
group who are abducting black people are
actually descendants of the Knights
Templar a Christian Military Order
founded in 1119 and which took part in
the Crusades there's a nod to this in
the film with the Templar helmet that
Jeremy was at the beginning of the movie
Pele also explained in the movies
commentary that the cult carrying out
the abductions and transplant surgeries
is called the red alchemist society in
fact all
all the attendance at the auction party
who've come to bid on Chris's body were
some form of red whether it's a
pocket-handkerchief red earrings red in
their ties red glasses or red lipstick a
little sign they're part of the red
alchemist society so it's intriguing
that in Earth a delays double is called
red and the tethered are all dressed in
red jumpsuits and notice also how
Adelaide's pale colored clothes get
stained red with blood as the film
progresses a clue to the twist ending
that Adelaide was originally more than
the tethered before she escaped in 1986
there are also some huge parallels
between the sunken place from get out
and the underground tunnels in us were
the teller de force to live in get out
the sunken place is a conceptual space
somewhere that cryst sinks into falling
below the surface while his captors
remain above peering down at him in us
the tethered exists below the surface in
abandoned underground areas which were
deliberately chosen in order to keep the
experiments a secret in get out chris's
bodies also literally taken downstairs
to the basement after he falls into the
sunken place for the second time and
it's also below ground level where the
actual brain surgery takes place
whenever he's trapped in the sunken
place chris becomes paralyzed and loses
control over much of his body
likewise in us the tethered have limited
control over their own bodies think of
those images we see of them shuffling
around the tunnels forced to imitate
their counterparts above the surface in
both films these characters have lost
much of their free will and autonomy
over their bodies after being subjected
to the secret societies experiments
however in each film the victims of
these experiments also show some ability
to break out as their captivity in us
young Adelaide's doppelganger below
ground has some ability to act
independently of her counterpart of both
ground and when Adelaide visits the Hall
of Mirrors and encounters her double the
doppelganger takes initiative and drags
her down inside the tunnels then
switches places with her also after the
tethered her abandoned Redd speaks of a
moment years later when a miracle
happened it seems like at that point the
connection between the tethered and a
counterpart suburb was broken or
weakened to the point where the tethered
could now act independently and with the
help of red they organized
evolution to rise up from below and
break free in get out the mad science of
the Armitage family employees to
transfer brains and replace the
consciousness of the host bodies doesn't
quite work as they'd like it to as they
have to allow a tiny part of the
original mind to remain actually the
piece of your brain connected to your
nervous system needs to stay put keeping
those intricate connections intact a
sliver of you will still be in there
somewhere
limited consciousness your existence
will be as a passenger an audience
you'll live in the same place and we see
examples and guess out of word the
original consciousness seeps through or
is able to take back control over their
body for example when Chris photographs
Logan the flash on the camera triggers
Andres mind to take control and he's
able to talk to Chris warning him to get
out there's also a moment in get out the
reveals which members of Rosa's family
might have been connected with the
experiments in us when Chris wakes up
after being imprisoned in the family
basement the TV switches on and plays a
video where Rosa's grandfather Roman
Armitage introduces the name of the
experiment that's about to be performed
on Chris as the coagula procedure our
order has been developing it for many
many years and it wasn't until recently
it was perfected Roman was a runner in
the 1930s he lost to Jesse Owens in the
qualifying round for the Berlin Olympics
and in the video Chris watches Roman
reveals at the Red Alchemist Society had
been trying to develop the brain
transplant procedure for many years
until his son Dean had a breakthrough
what that means is that if the secret
society was struggling with this attempt
to transfer their consciousness into new
bodies is quite possible that over the
years as they tried different procedures
and ideas at one point they either
deliberately or accidentally created the
tethered for example what if red was
wrong than the tethered weren't created
to control people above-ground but
instead with the result of a red
alchemists experiment that tried but
failed to create clones so members of
that society could carry on living when
their original bodies died was it
interesting not to get outside iya of
two minds sharing one body in the
opening scene of earth where you can see
a VHS tape of the movie the man with two
brains next the TV set the man with two
brains is an 80
sci-fi comedy starring Steve Martin as a
brain surgeon working with a mad
scientist who's developed a technique to
keep brains alive outside their body and
the pair end up transferring a living
brain from a murder victim into another
person's body of course get outside 'ya
of to mind sharing one body is flipped
in us where we have the idea of two
bodies sharing one mind a striking
visual parallel between the film's is
how we see tears flow down the faces of
the characters who've been experimented
on what's common to each one is that
they've either been physically or
mentally imprisoned and are being
confronted with the horrors of what the
shadowy group have inflicted upon them
crisp tears up when Missy manipulates
his sadness about his dead mother and
absent father and hypnotizes him sending
him into the sunken place for the first
time
Adelaide cries when she's confronted by
red in her home and red herself also
cries as she tells either late about the
terrible physical and emotional pain she
went through as a tethered individual
when she was forced to copy every action
that Adelaide took above-ground in get
out when Chris talks to the housemaid
Georgina about being nervous around
white people tears run down Georgina's
face as her original consciousness
battles with the transplanted brain that
was forcibly implanted in her and after
Chris releases Walter from the sunken
place by flashing him with his camera
just before Walter turns the gun on
himself
a single tear falls down his cheek
showing his internal horror and mental
torment as he realizes this is his only
way out of the prison that Rose's
grandfather has placed him in by the way
there could be an interesting connection
between how the flashes from Chris's
camera managed to free both Andre and
Walter from the sunken place and the
lightning from the electrical storm that
was going on the night that young a
delays double was able to break out of
the tunnels in us another shared idea in
both movies is a use of rabbits to
signify the horror of the situation at
hand
geordan Peter said that although he
knows the fluffy animals were adorable
he finds their scissor-like ears
terrifying in get out opening scene
flanagan and Alan's classic song run
rabbit run plays while Jeremy attacks
and abducts Andre in Earth Adelaide
tells her daughter Sora who's an athlete
to run during the tethers home invasion
and Zora also has rabbits printed on
their clothes such as this top here and
the
word on her top in this scene is the
Vietnamese word for rabbits like the
tethered rabbits live underground are
often used for experiments and to add to
the horror rule rabbit was the tethered
only source of food when they lived
below the surface and doesn't link back
from us to get out it's the bowl of dry
fruit loops on the table at the Tyler's
vacation home and during a scene there
Adelaide's son Jason picks up a fruit
loop and eats it it's an intriguing nod
to get out creepy scene of Rose eating a
bowl of the brightly colored sugary
cereal on one piece at a time and
sipping on a glass of milk while she
looks for a new victim so to get out an
earth signal the dawn of a Jordan Peele
Cinematic Universe well peel himself has
said that the two movies are part of the
same project and around the time of
GuestHouse release in 2017 he also told
business insider that he had four other
social thrillers he planned to release
in the next 10 years so that means
there's another three left to go in this
series and it seems quite possible
they'll connect to get out in Earth's in
similar ways peelers explained that the
best and scariest monsters in the world
are human beings and what were capable
of especially when we get together he
said that he's been working on these
premises about these different social
demons these innately human monsters
that have woven into the fabric of how
we think and how we interact and each
one of his movies is going to be about a
different one of these social demons
Peale could clearly used the red
alchemist society as a sort of secret
group of antagonists that connects
across all his movies I expect that as
is already the case with us and get out
you'll be able to watch any of peels
film separately and enjoy them
regardless of whether you've seen the
others however spotting these
connections will be fun for fans of
peels work especially as the writer
director loves to pack each of his
movies with tons of Easter eggs and
references and if you missed any of the
other crucial Easter eggs and hidden
symbolism and us you can tap here to
watch my full breakdown of all the
secret clues that revealed the twist
ending now I'd love to hear about any
other get-out connections or cool Easter
eggs you spotted in us let me know in
the comments below and if you enjoy more
deep dives theories and
behind-the-scenes secrets about your
favorite movies be sure to subscribe and
tap the bell to get all my new videos
tapleft for that full breakdown of all
the secret clues you missed in earth or
tap right for another video you're sure
to like thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers